[Music]
you
[Music]
Jim Michael we're talking about the
quickest most stylish way out the door
this spring this summer what is it Jim
wearing a pair of loafers three loafers
how to have loafers you know for many
seasons we thought no who wears loafers
weren't but but loafers are back there
improved and you got them two ways one
for the office and one for the weekend
this is actually the same loafer that
they're wearing just show how it goes
with any outfit this is the first loafer
you got to get but I also think you
should need more than one loafer we've
got all kinds of loafers all kinds of
materials from canvas to sway to leather
tassel plain taupe any a lot you know
it's summer you want to look good you
know maybe you don't want to wear thick
sold heavy shoe there's certainly a
range of them which muscle tees off
petunia what would work with let start
with the business look here when you and
I were young men you couldn't be loafing
at the job now you're telling me to loaf
with the job it was a penny loafer that
a lot of guys were wearing and it was
just too casual it had a little bit more
of a rounded kind of a bumper toe you
know this is a rough floor it's a little
bit slimmer without being too slick
those old loafers they would sort they
would show a lot of your foot but this
is only showing very little of your foot
it makes it a little more business
appropriate and you've also got it with
that but that suit is seasoned which we
keep talking about is that light gray
which you know you say goes with
everything but talk about the casual
picture so I think a lot of guys might
be like oh if I wear black pants I gotta
wear black well right which I was very
surprised to see abut so why does that
work it wouldn't be inappropriate to
wear black but the brown just warms up
the whole outfit it's also gonna be a
little bit heavy for this very light
color jacket so the brown actually keeps
the whole outfit springy
you know it's summer you want to look
good it's a great vacation look and this
is a great work look you've got it both
ways why do you guys just be standing
looking so good like a half you got to
respect to love her stay tuned we got
more coming your way
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]